I just wanted to bring up because I
don't want to you know you're been very
gracious with your time and but I just
wanted to bring up something that I
think is amazing which is you and the
band have done this very cool thing
where you want people who are hearing
impaired or deaf to be able to come and
enjoy a concert as well so you've
figured out a way where they can and
where you can enhance the enhance the
vibrations of the music a lot of our
critics say it's the best way to
experience our culture because you can't
hear the music
but what is it exactly because I didn't
understand what it was they are called
sub packs
uh Dakota my partner gave me one as a
gift because she's she'd seen someone
online experiencing whatever they're
experiencing with this it's kind of like
body armor that you put on
and plug it in and it and it connects to
the base
uh Billy eilish's brother um Phineas
Phineas yeah where's one on stage
because if you're if you're on stage it
can give you help you know where the one
is where the cake is yep
so she had seen this lady use it in the
in the Herring hearing impaired you know
deaf community
and she said you should use this somehow
and so we started doing that and um it's
been so amazing and should get better
and better so we have I don't know
whether it's 10 or 20 now every night um
of those packs and so if you're hearing
impaired we have an an area where we
have a signer
and you put on this pack and you can
feel
the show that's really lovely that's
fantastic it would be great if that
caught on and more people were doing
that yeah well that you know like like a
lot of things in our show they're
expensive yeah so and until um the price
comes down you know but but they're
amazing the things that people do to
consider other people are just wonderful
yeah you don't hear about them as much
as you hear about the shitty stuff no we
had definitely okay yeah but they are
out there and so I've been I've been um
I just worked out a way actually because
I do a little bit of sign in in our show
dressed as an alien I just worked out
how to
change the sign language to fit the
country we're in because last year I
could only do it in American
but we've been chilly or something and
I'm it would be like speaking American
on stage right so you've got to figure
out a way I've just worked out how to do
that I'm excited about it I think the
key is you keep evolving you have to
keep evolving you have to keep changing
you have to keep there's no point where
you say well
God we've done it no never yeah I
learned from Brian Eno who came to kind
of rescue our band in 2006. he came in
like a like an excited puppy and he was
he was 59 actually when you met him yeah
and he would always be learning and
excited about learning
and I really just loved that and stole
it it's funny you say it's not stealing
it well you did steal Bruce
Springsteen's diet uh and he'll get you
for that but the and I'm gonna steal it
now too it's not stealing if something
inspires you I'm at the exact right age
to be inspired in both directions yeah
and I love it and sometimes I have to
overcome a bit of professional jealousy
occasionally to to allow myself to be
inspired by something that's maybe more
successful or that I think is better
yeah I think we all struggle with that
um but there is inspiration everywhere
not just in music but in film and in
everything science all over the place
and then you said about not having
anything else to achieve I think that
whether it's a combination of what what
I try and learn outside of music or
whether it's age or whatever
it doesn't really feel about trying to
achieve anything anymore yeah it just
feels like
Phil and I were talking yesterday it
feels like we got the job that we really
wanted and now it's just we can just do
it yeah
does that make sense it makes perfect
sense we wanted to be this
Stadium band that really made people
connect and sync together and not see
the differences as much as the
similarities as Hallmark as that sounds
yeah that's that's our real
goal and now and now it is that just
it's the doing of it yeah no every day
is the doing us yeah and you realize in
a way that maybe the drive that you had
or the ego is to is to sort of rocket
boost you to a place where you can
actually be a bit more useful yeah you
know it's not about winning this and
beating that person anymore it's like no
it's just make something that some
people might like I have found in some
of that energy that I had in my 20s and
30s and you know I letting go of that
when you can do it is
is such a better way to live yeah I I
mean if you can let go of it that's
you're better than me I have to
consciously override I mean I have to
consciously
listen to a lot of weird feelings and
luckily have some tools to help me these
days to not be owned by that feeling
yeah and one of the hardest ones is that
oh man Harry Styles's new song is better
than our new song or something like that
right luckily I've been taught how to
very quickly be just inspired by it I
feel like you know what it's awesome and
he's awesome and I love him and I'm just
going to work harder I just saw him at
Coachella last summer and he was dancing
and turned around and I saw that he had
an H on the left butt cheek and an s on
the right butt cheek and I thought
Jesus
that's an innovation I need to steal I
need to walk around outside the O takes
care of itself
I'll get a little apostrophe put over my
okay my anus
um this uh this was really a blast we're
gonna finish on that I do you think
there's a better place
um I love talking to people who are
insanely talented uh but also
uh interested in connecting and
interested in the journey because we're
all just trying to figure it out and
you've been really lovely and I do want
to say you gave me a remarkable gift
when I walked in the door that I is
gorgeous and I'll cherish it no problem
yeah it's a Rolls-Royce
1958 yeah Silver Shadow yeah we give
them to everyone
That's The Power of soft rock
you're so self-centered and you're
giving out rolls royces it's just a bit
of a clash anyway thank you so much
thank you and thank you all for coming
I'm so happy and we love you man it's I
think we came on your show 20 years ago
you came on many times and just uh
absolute pleasure yeah on you know the
first few times and you just like how
did we get here on American you know so
right magical and mystical and you were
kind to us and that doesn't ever go away
oh that's so nice well thank you well
God I mean we were honored honored to
have you yeah but you could have been a
dick and you were really kind and it was
a good example I mean on a Wednesday
then yeah
all right thanks everybody thank you